[Music]
I'm sure you've heard about a couple of
scandals that have gone down in Bekaa
seas and Garret Lincoln having been on
three shows in the franchise is there
anything that you think production could
have done differently to kind of handle
any of that or maybe addresses the
casting process for me I mean I know how
it was for me after the application they
called I'm assuming they did the
background check and you know I know
that I added peanut KUB but yeah I do
think now you learn from your mistakes
and I think now it's time for the and
I'm sure they will for the production
company to say let's dig in a little bit
more to back up on who you're putting on
the show you don't want this stuff give
me a problem I don't think it's fun
probably for the show to have to deal
with I know it's not right to be
publicizing these people who have done
this stuff so I do think it's time for
them to change their their ways Garrett
released a statement after it came out
that he liked some of these different
controversial memes on Instagram and it
said in part quote I never realized the
power behind a mindless double tap on
Instagram he also said I do not want my
social media to define who I am so as
someone who's gotten a really big social
media following from the show as many
people do now I just wanted your take on
that
you know we I'm sure if I look back on
my tweets from 2010 I'd have said things
I don't like either yours you know
uneducated or unknowledgeable or your
opinion is off and wrong there are
things that I've done in my past that
now today I'll say if I've grown past in
and a better person because of it but I
think that is the risk that we have in
today's world is everything you do is
pretty much documented and and who you
are in the public eye no matter if you
are a celebrity if you are famous if you
are known you're not known people are
watching and I think even one person
watching Garrett's social-media account
would have what seemed the things he was
like and go done this is the character
that I think here it is so I don't know
if I agree with he doesn't want his
social media to it already done
[Music]